today I want to talk to you about how to
handle the highs and lows of life our
Patrick mid David and today I want to
talk to you about something that over
the years totally frustrated me so much
that I finally had to figure out a way
to create a formula for it for me to
stay sane instead of driving myself nuts
you see in life life is rarely ever all
good or all bad life is normally filled
with lots of highs and lots of lows it
is rarely staying in the equilibrium of
everything just being good and dandy
there's a lot of things that happen in
life life events happen you know one day
we could be graduating from college and
we're so excited the next minute we're
breaking up with our girlfriend or our
boyfriend next min and we can't get a
job or if we got a job we got fired than
our friends don't want to talk to us
because we got into a big fight over
something small and now you don't have a
lot of money in your hands because you
are in debt $22,000 then you meet a girl
but you don't have the money to marry
her and she dumps you because her father
doesn't like you and next thing you know
you meet the love of your life you guys
hit it off things are going very good
you land a job you get a big race
everything is great then a relative
passes away then you go to a funeral
then you get married two months later
that's life that's just it's life is
rarely in the middle it's normally highs
and lows of life and two illustrations I
made and this is what I've seen with
studying a lot of different people over
the years I've noticed the formula for
madness is very simple what I notice a
lot of times is that this is life highs
and lows I notice a lot of people stay
in their highs too long meaning somebody
starts a business they do a grand
opening party and they keep partying for
two months then two months later their
party stops because they go out of
business
so they too excited about the fact that
I just opened up a business or somebody
gets a college degree and they celebrate
four months because they got a college
degree they don't realize the purpose of
it is to start a career so then they go
into the
and they say in depression for way too
long I'm not a good person I'm a loser
I'm not smart I'm not this and they
mourn way too long and this becomes a
trend in life and you know what this
does this drives people nuts what I've
learned over the years is this is how
life needs to be meaning like a
heartbeat it goes right its heartbeat
right after each other it doesn't go and
stay because if I don't breathe what
happens I die see here as an
illustration of staying sane when you
have a victory you go up quick will you
come back to equilibrium
another quick victory you come back to
normal another small victory you come
back to normal a crisis happens somebody
passes away you come back to normal you
have a big victory to get a raise you
come back to normal over here your kid
breaks a leg you come back to normal no
matter what happens if you stay at the
highs too long or if you stay at the
lows too long you are going to drive
yourself nuts the key is to go up
celebrate your victory quick and come
back to normal again because you still
don't walk on water and the key is to
when you have terrible times that
happens come back up because life is
going to be okay this is about where
life is that but in order for you as an
entrepreneur as a human being as anybody
who's doing something big with your life
if you are planning to stay sane for the
rest of your life you have got to learn
how to manage the loads of your life as
well as the highs of your life it's
never a good idea to take two of them
way too serious where you dwell into it
and it takes you out for many many
months at a time
it's my message of the week to employees
be sure to subscribe on the bottom and
comment on the channel
you